well thank you very much Dean cylinder
as Garr said I was in the advice with
the Advisory Council several years ago
and got to know Garth very well and I
can certainly attest to a great
selection that was made in Garth being a
Dean of our school well good afternoon
everyone it's a pleasure to be back here
at at my alma mater and and the GSB fact
I was a member of the first graduating
class back in 1967 when this built
building first opened as the brand new
Stanford Business School and it really
makes you feel old that is as you come
back and see that the new school is is
soon to be open it is also ironic that
early next year as Garth mentioned just
a few months from now that I will retire
from from Wells Fargo 42 years after I
first joined General Mills having just
graduated from the GSB and as again as
Garth mentioned and and I hope that you
all well when you are contemplating your
next career move would stay and and be
more flexible than I was because it is
true that when I was thinking of what to
do upon graduation I I really did not
know for sure what I wanted to do but I
was very certain of what I did not want
to do I was certain that I did not want
to ever work for a bank or work in New
York City and a mere eight years later I
became an executive of citi bank at 53rd
and Park Avenue so keep an open mind
since I have been around this business
world a long time and about ready to
hang it up as as we used to say on the
athletic field what I thought I would do
this afternoon is share some thoughts
with you entitled what have I learned
since business school I hope this does
not cause you to quit school and ask for
a tuition refund power
as you will soon hear I am quite
passionate about certain ideas that have
worked for me over my business career
and have not usually been an important
element of the curriculum at leading
graduate schools of business I began
experimenting with these ideas shortly
after my first general management job in
1969 at General Mills but I did not put
all of these ideas into an actual
marketplace test until I joined Norwest
in Minneapolis back in 1986 as a vice
chairman have the Banking Group there
let me briefly summarize our results
from 1986 to now our assets have grown
from 20 billion to 1.3 trillion our net
income from a hundred million to an
estimate of twelve billion dollars this
year that analysts are forecasting our
market cap from 100 from 800 million to
135 billion a compound rate of 25
percent we had 15,000 team members back
there back then we have two hundred and
eighty two thousand today we had seven
hundred stores today we have ten
thousand we have also today ranked is
the 14th most admired company in Fortune
magazine's annual survey and Barron's
magazine and the United States and bears
Barron's magazine ranks as in the top 25
of the most respected companies in the
world I mentioned these things only to
demonstrate what I think is the power of
some of the things that I have learned
since business school and these
quantitative and qualitative
measurements at least give an indication
that there has been some value to those
ideas I would also I also want to
mention that I've had the privilege of
meeting faculty of this great school on
many occasions and in many different
ways where I have spoken about what I
thought
was important and important changes that
needed to be made in the curriculum of
all business schools and I'm pleased to
see that the changes that have been made
by the GSB in the last five or ten years
and are very consistent with some of the
thoughts and ideas I'll convey to you
today what I learned at the GSB and in
my engineering courses so in terms of
quantitative methods and Finance
accounting strategy and marketing were
obviously of great value and we're very
important and I believe are very
important to business success
but on the margin they were not even in
the same ballpark and important as the
concepts of leadership people as a
competitive advantage and what I would
describe as management by culture but I
am getting a little ahead of myself and
and and I want to mention that I think
one of the values of the engineering
background that I had even though you
should all feel good that those of you
who cross bridges bridges at least or
work in tall skyscrapers that I was not
a real engineer as such I was an
industrial engineer at Stanford and
industrial engineers really was a
quantitative application of business
principles in fact many of the
professor's were in both of the Business
School in industrial engineering
department and it was things like
statistical analysis quantitative
business methods operation of research
production efficiency computer science
and so on
we all did take the same basic
engineering courses of math physics and
and and so forth but while my liberal
arts classmates were playing volleyball
in the afternoon we engineers were in
the lab doing work when not on the
baseball field at least in my case and
although I never practiced as an
engineer I do think that the engineering
background did significantly influence
the process that I use in making
decisions and that process does appear
to be different from that of some other
large companies CEOs my engineering
background influenced my extensive use
of a deductive reasoning the importance
of analyzing data intelligently the Bill
to ask relevant questions to challenge
existing assumptions and and do
sensitivity analysis on the various
alternatives that could be modelled on
what decision to make in short to
thoroughly understand the quantitative
elements and the risk versus reward
aspects of the ultimate decision but I
also learned a lot outside the classroom
especially on the athletic field and
through actual business experience by
making a lot of mistakes but hopefully
never making the same mistake twice ie
learning from one's mistakes the most
important things I have learned in my 42
years in business in 34 years in
financial services is that success in
the business world especially in the
world of financial services or other
service companies is less about brains
at the 99 percent level and more about
people development motivation coaching
leadership teamwork integrity culture
community involvement vision values and
a broad understanding of a variety of
business disciplines especially
interpersonal relations intelligence
above the 99% level might even be
inversely correlated with some of these
attributes GMAT scores just don't
measure these skills in today's business
world we need broad generalists to
successfully run large and complex
companies we desperately need leaders
this is where Sports comes in at least
for me from the age of 4 through 21 I
played some form of competitive
athletics for 2 to 3 hours almost every
day sports helped me to understand human
nature teamwork and how emotions impact
performance sports helped me to
appreciate the value of personal
discipline physical conditioning in the
use of time but perhaps most importantly
athletics introduced me to the power of
interpersonal dynamics I experiences I
know many of you have that teamwork and
team spirit causes a group of
individuals to perform well above well
above the level of their individual
abilities in basketball for instance
it's not the 5 best players who become
champions
is the best five players who do so so
what does it take to be successful in
business well if I had to do all over
again
perhaps the MBA I received is not the
best degree to lead a company to success
after all perhaps you should seek four
very different degrees first get a
degree in believing believe in the
enormous talent of people people at all
levels of your organization to receive
to receive a degree in believing your
dissertation must answer this question
why do many people inner business being
bright well-educated energetic wanting
to make a difference and in a few years
feel bored ignored unfulfilled and
unimportant why is that
today's MBAs need a second degree in
affirming they must affirm their belief
that almost everyone in any
organizations profit or not profit wants
to contribute wants to do a good job
receiving this degree requires that we
treat everyone in our organization with
respect as equals as talented people as
important members of our team working
together toward a common goal regardless
of rank educational level or
compensation
third I would recommend a master's
degree in M and F that stands for
motivation and fun yes you heard
correctly fun I know it may be
surprising to you but even bankers
should have fun
I define fun as working with people to
help them get excited about what they're
doing help create an enjoyable work
environment have fun and then recognize
them publicly with great fanfare for a
job well done when people aren't having
fun when they're not recognized for
outstanding performance when no one says
thanks they do become disengaged and
feel unimportant recognition I believe
is on the margin more important than
salaries benefits and bonuses because
most all companies pay competitively it
is corporate America's most under
utilized motivational to try thanking
someone too much for a job well done
you can't do it so you need a master's
degree in believing affirming motivation
fund and then you need a doctorate a
doctorate in leadership the most
advanced and important degree possible
what is leadership there are probably as
many definitions as there are leaders I
am sure many of you have your own I
define leadership as the act of
establishing and communicating a vision
of the future and the art of motivating
others to align with and embrace that
vision leaders enable people to do great
to do such great things that they
believe that they can continue doing
them leaders take people from where they
are to where they've never been that's
why leadership is the critical skill for
sustainable business success but great
leaders give power to their teams they
do not monopolize it you cannot share a
vision unless you share the power to
achieve it leaders don't point fingers
they point direction they show away by
personal example I'm sure everyone here
today is still familiar with Maslow's
hierarchy of needs which I did learn in
both my engineering and MBA classes it
arranges individual needs in a pyramid
as you well know Safety's at the bottom
moving up through food shelter at the
top a feeling of self-worth in the same
way I believe there's a pyramid of tools
to lead any biz
to greatness importantly but at the
bottom there are the fundamentals of the
business enterprise the accounting the
computer literacy literacy quantitative
skills you move up the pyramid to
finance manufacturing kill skills sales
marketing and then to the top empowering
people motivation recognition
communication skills and at the apex
leadership the need for speed and
adaptability in today's world leave zero
room in my opinion for dictatorship
centralized command and control and in
the worst sense of the word hierarchy
hierarchy assumes that the higher up you
are the better you are making decisions
here's a secret almost every person at
Wells Fargo knows more about their
specific work than I do
teller assistants people commercial
banker store managers you name it they
all know more about the needs of their
customers because they know more there's
no need to waste time coming to me for a
decision make the decision yourself and
let me know what you decided if you
think I can help you to make better
decisions I'm available to do so
I remember reading books in my MBA class
that said the maximum number of people
who should report to someone else to
have what was called effective control
was six to eight but never more than 10
baloney it should be 15 to 20 at least
maybe even more the more people who
report to you the better it forces you
to delegate give responsibilities and
not interfere it allows others the
satisfaction of running their own shows
show and being responsible for their own
results it also reduced layers between
you and the customer the truth is I
didn't run Wells Fargo we have nearly
100 businesses each with their own fully
loaded profit and loss we are very
decentralized the business heads are
totally responsible for their businesses
they report to six group heads who are
the CEOs for their group of businesses
and they should act more like coaches
than bosses my job was to select the
best people to run those businesses and
those groups let them do it
coach them so they learn even faster and
ensure we have a strong internal check
and balanced audit process that verifies
that they are adhering to the principles
and the policies that we've agreed upon
people at the top should above all be
leaders
quite often they lie they act like
managers managers administer leaders
innovate managers to rely on systems
leaders rely on people managers need
control leaders rely on trust managers
work on getting things right leaders
work on the right Thanks
at Wells Fargo we believe personal
leadership is the key to success we
believe the answer to every problem
issue or opportunity in our company is
already known by some person or team in
the company the leader only has to find
that person listen and help affect the
change by the way the people with the
best answers are not always the people
with the most stripes true leaders do
not demand loyalty they create it they
use conflict among diverse points of
view to enable the team to reach new
insights they exert influence by
reinforcing values at Wells Fargo we
manage these hundred different
businesses spanning a wide geography
across all of North America and
internationally by sharing a corporate
culture that people believe in and align
with not by command and control or
hierarchy a good leader inspires a team
to have confidence in him or her
a great leader inspires a team to have
confidence in themselves this may
surprise you at Wells Fargo our most
important constituent is not our
customer customers it's our people
because our people have the greatest
influence on our customers and how our
customers perceive Wells Fargo our
people influence the attitude of our
customers more than anything else
our people are key to customer
satisfaction and increasing market share
so my job is CEO the past 18 and 15
years it was really quite simple
cause the organization to focus on
customers recognized that the key to
consistent bottom line growth is
actually the top-line revenue
growth hire retain reward and recognize
the best people coach them to be
effective leaders make sure they care in
selecting people I don't care how much a
person knows until I know how much they
care give people the responsibility and
accountable to run their own business
encourage them to be active in their
communities to be leaders in their
communities create describe and
communicate the corporate culture its
vision and values make sure everyone is
having some fun
then just get out of their way and cheer
as they receive as they achieve
consistent record-breaking
industry-leading results in short what I
learned on the athletic fields and from
40-plus years in business in the
business world is that success is all
about people especially in financial
services or other service businesses at
Wells Fargo we call it people as a
competitive advantage few of any of
other larger institutions really walk
that talk our emphasis on people is the
foundation of our company's culture our
growth in our success because we are so
decentralized and reliable results our
individual business leaders which number
in the thousands by the way we manage
the overall company by culture shared
vision and values and coaching
incidentally I don't remember these
concepts ever being presented let alone
taught when I was at the Stanford
Business School so what I would now like
to do is give you some examples of how
culture influences our behavior and
decision-making process I believe these
examples apply to all businesses but
again in particular those that have a
direct service relationship with their
customers take acquisition strategy for
example at Wells Fargo we will only do
those acquisitions where the where the
company that we are considering
acquiring has a culture that is similar
to Wells Fargo's our culture is
described in this vision and values
booklet that has been that is updated
about every two years and was first
published about 20
years ago it describes in great detail
our vision values culture and operating
philosophy if anyone of you is
interested in a copy of this I have a
few of them here so early on in a
discussion discussion stage of a
possible acquisition we will give the
the principles this booklet and ask them
to compare their culture to ours we
asked them to estimate how well such a
vision and values would be accepted if
the cultures are considered to be
incompatible we would terminate further
discussions a prime example of the role
of culture and acquisition
decision-making process was when other
large banks were buying investment banks
in the late 1990s we did not we felt
that the investment banking the culture
was incompatible with ours we are a
relationship focused company investment
banks are often transactionally focused
we are a team focused company with team
incentives investment banks are often
made up of independent minded highly
paid stars who are individually
incentive some investment banks often
cross the line in our belief in terms of
ethical behavior and often take
excessive risk relative to the rewards
we predicted that 6 out of 10 of these
investment bank acquisitions by
commercial banks would not work we were
wrong 9 out of 10 didn't work in fact
that's how we met missed the mess other
large banks and investment banks are in
right now
management by culture told us that some
of the actions taken by others were
morally and ethically wrong other
actions taken just did not make any
risk/reward sense to us
management by culture saved us but
things change because of these cultural
and ethical lapses the investment
banking industry has dramatically
changed with the recent demise of
Merrill Lynch Lehman Brothers Bear
Stearns and and many smaller firms that
that actually left us in nineteen in the
1990s there are only two broad product
line investment banks left namely
Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley and
they are actually bank holding companies
today we believe that this radical
industry realignment has permanently
changed the competitive environment
and the end business practice such that
Wells Fargo can now be in the investment
banking business without compromising
our culture and values in combination
with Wachovia and in just the past year
we have because of the investment
banking expertise that Wachovia had we
have gone from being a very small player
to likely ranking in the top ten of US
investment banks this year and we think
we'll be in the top five within the next
few years our company's culture and
belief in people as the competitive
advantage also causes us to handle
layoffs and staff reductions different
from others now we know it is often
necessary because of acquisitions or
other downsizing that positions must be
eliminated but eliminating positions
does not necessarily mean that good
loyal experienced and talented people
need to be fired when our competitors do
acquisitions they can hardly wait to
tell the street how many people will be
fired and what the cost savings will be
we in contrast don't typically do
acquisitions for cost savings but rather
for revenue growth cost savings are
usually a one-time profit gain revenue
growth is the gift that keeps on giving
we do eliminate positions but we attempt
to find other jobs for the people being
displaced to find other jobs for the
people being displaced given the
turnover that exists in our company
there are literally thousands of
positions available each year that can
be filled by people displaced by
acquisitions and downsize downsizing we
call it retain and retrain since we
believe in people as a competitive
advantage we want to keep all the good
experienced people that we can on our
team another area we differ from other
banks was our early commitment to and
continued belief that we are a financial
services company much more than a bank
for over two decades now less than 50%
of our revenue comes from traditional
banking traditional banking is about a
five hundred billion dollar industry the
total financial services industry which
in addition to banking includes
insurance investment banking asset
management mortgage consumer finance
leasing and other products is a 2.7
trillion dollars in size over five times
larger than banking
it is hard to grow when you excuse me
the leading bank in a given state may
have 20% to 30% main banking share in
that state it is hard to grow when you
have such a large share however this
banking share leader will usually have
less than a 5% financial services market
share in that state that means there is
plenty of room for growth if you were a
financial services company while others
follow the advice of Wall Street
consulting firms and conventional
business school teaching of being
strategically focused ie and narrow
product line and some were basically
mono lines Wells Fargo has maintained a
very broad product line delivering about
every financial product and service
purchased by mass market and high net
worth consumers as well as large medium
and small businesses a lot of people
including some of my Stanford Business
School professors think you shouldn't
try to be all things to all people
admittedly it is hard to do but if you
can figure out how to affect it deliver
through cross selling all the financial
products needed by all the potential
customers in your marketplace there are
enormous competitive advantages
diversity of income streams economics of
scale and skill and compelling
profitability through my positions on
board of directors and and the number of
customer relationships that we have I
have helped to nudge other companies to
consider expanding their strategy and
selling more products to their existing
customers and more services and it has
also worked for them it was always
fascinated me that a multi-product
financial company like Wells Fargo was
considered by some as almost a
conglomerate too broad and not focused
so what so I had asked these people is
Walmart a conglomerate oh no they would
say are they focused absolutely they are
focused well what does Walmart not self
I try to get people to understand is
that is that Wells Fargo is first and
foremost a distributor
it's a distributor of commodity
financial products most all financial
products are similar thus we have much
more in common with other distributors
of commodity products like Walmart and
Lowe's than we did with Goldman Sachs or
countrywide just like Walmart and Lowe's
are unique or our uniqueness is the way
we distribute those products not the
products themselves consistent organic
revenue growth through cross selling is
probably Wells Fargo's most distinctive
skill our average retail household has
5.9 products and over 1 & 4 has over 8
products these are by far the highest
cross sell ratios ratios in the industry
and about twice the industry average our
average wholesale customer has 6.4
products with us our middle-market
commercial banking division averages
close to 10 products per customer again
about double the industry average
organic double-digit revenue growth is
essential for consistent double-digit
profit growth we have grown our revenue
in a double-digit compound rate for 20
years and therefore our we have had the
profitability and market share growth
that I've already mentioned to you since
many of mono lines have crashed and
burns and and/or been acquired more
company more companies now seem to be
interested in cross selling and
broadening their product line we have a
20-year head start on these
johnny-come-lately and I'm glad we do
let me now mention the need for
disciplined acquisitions and this is
required in any company in any industry
I've never understood the comment I know
we paid a lot for this deal but it is
that it is a strategic acquisition if
you paid so much that you don't get a
decent return what could be strategic
about it a strategic deal should mean
that it fits so well is it you should
make a pile of money let me ask you this
about acquisition strategy if you
believe as I do that practically all
financial segments and it's true of many
other industries are cyclical
when during the cycle should you acquire
at the top or at the bottom when do most
people buy I'm going to ask you how many
get that question right I'll leave that
to your classroom most people only want
to buy great companies and so do we
but of course they pay high premiums
Wells Fargo often buys fixer-uppers
companies who have had a temporary
setback but still have good people and
good customers and a solid franchise we
pay a lower price because there is more
work to do which will require more time
and perhaps additional investment but
with our broad product line our superior
business model our strong experience
management team and our cross selling
prowess we can usually within three
years get the troubled company growing
revenue at double-digit rates just like
the rest of our company a good example
of this strategy the guard mentioned was
the acquisition of walk quote or a cobia
Bank last fall for twelve point seven
billion dollars a company whose market
cap was over ninety billion dollars a
couple years before that and has the
number one banking market share in eight
fast-growing southeastern states as well
as other great markets yes we have some
problems to fix but I believe this will
turn out to be the best and most
profitable acquisition in banking him in
banking history and among the best in
all of corporate history we also often
buy smaller companies rather than larger
companies because their culture is more
similar to ours the implementation risk
are less and so is the risk of being
wrong most of our large Bank competitors
buy only large companies when we do a
deal the financial projections must
clear two hurdles a minimum 15 percent
internal rate of return and accretive to
existing stockholders by no later than
year 3 both are important if you have a
p/e ratio higher than your acquisition
target it is relatively relatively easy
to be accretive but there is usually a
reason for the p/e difference the target
has probably been growing at a slower
rate if you give the sellers most of
your p/e difference you will soon grow
more slowly as well
your PE will fall requiring both an IRR
and an ANA creative hurdle rate ensures
you only do deals that will add value no
matter how you elect to pay for them
stat stock cash or a combination of both
most companies don't do that some
companies set their IRR hurdle rate too
low in my opinion at their so-called
katz cost of capital something they
probably learned in business school as I
did who wants to earn only their cost of
capital
that's a sure step toward mediocrity
others think any acquisition that is a
creative is is good without considering
the inherent p/e differences let me ask
you this question should you take
actions based upon the advice of
so-called industry visionaries pundits
the media and Wall Street experts when I
first started running major banking
businesses in the late teen 9019 70s I
was told my my right by my boss that
branches were dead and paper checks were
history we should start reducing both
immediately while there are more
branches today than there have ever been
and they increase every year only in the
past couple years 35 years later are we
seeing paper checks decline in the 1980s
I was told that the mortgage business is
a lousy business and we should get out
of it in the early 1990s I was told that
banking margins were falling so rapidly
and non-bank competitors were growing
market share so fast that banking was
all about cutting costs the cost cutters
would ultimately win in the late 1990s I
was told that the internet would make
branches obsolete Bill Gates said banks
were dinosaurs by the early 2000s
everything was reversed it was now all
about revenue growth not cus cut I was
also told branches were now so valuable
we should open them by the thousands as
we know those visionaries were
consistently wrong ladies and gentlemen
it is important to listen to the
futurist the pundits the media and Wall
Street because there is usually some
rationale to their positions
but in my opinion don't do anything
until you see signs that customers are
actually voting with their feet look for
the earliest possible signs of radical
change if you don't see any stay away
from the blue
and customers I said use your feet don't
look at I ball as a reason for market
valuations contrary to the industry
we've been opening new stores in
acquiring stores through acquisitions at
the same pace practically for two
decades you're continuing to do so we
never stopped or restarted and we've
always focused on revenue over
cost-cutting we also developed what is
now considered the best integrated
internet banking channel in the industry
and it serves all of our customers
personal business and investment needs
through one single sign-on whether that
person enters for their personal
accounts their business accounts or
their wealth management account
customers can navigate from one to the
other easily and efficiently global
finance magazine just rated our internet
offering as the best in the world
during the internet glory days unlike
the pundits and consulting companies and
many of our competitors we never saw the
Internet as a competing channel we saw
it as complementing our other
distribution channels and and the vast
majority of all of our customers are
actually multiple channel users they use
our stores the internet the ATMs and the
telephone we never saw nor expected
customers to suddenly stop using their
primary channel and immediately go
exclusively to a new channel we believed
that they did begin to shift they
wouldn't they would shift gradually and
such our modern and in such a moderate
pace that we can reconfigure our
distribution network accordingly many of
our competitors during the internet
craze closed their branches in
anticipation of a major change in
consumer and customer behavior and then
reversed all of that a few years later
let me now mention scale versus skill
how many times do you hear CEO say I
need to get bigger to be better I don't
buy that you get bigger by being better
you don't get better by being bigger
scale is certainly important in some
business but is often overrated for
example in banking I would say over a
hundred billion dollars in assets or so
skill is much more important than scale
skill is finding the best way to do
something in one place
store or with a customer and then
replicating that over your entire
network that's the only advantage to me
of being big you get to take a good idea
and multiply it of times versus maybe
less than a hundred times for a smaller
company otherwise size can be a
deterrent to organic growth why because
you often lose touch with your customers
and team members bureaucracy sets in
hierarchy rules you lose speed to market
and fast decision making how about risk
management well you can't be considered
the best financial services company in
the industry unless you're the best at
managing risk risk of all forms credit
risk interest rate risk and operational
risk all segments of the financial
services industry are cyclical and it's
quite common that towards the end of the
positive side of the cycle asset values
get elevated in risk spreads decline to
a level beyond in some cases far beyond
their fundamentals only if you are
disciplined diversified and have skilled
and experienced managers and leaders
that have reduced that have reduced your
exposure to such over valuations can you
avoid the write downs as these assets
are eventually valued significantly
lower we only have to look at what
happened in late 2007 when the collapse
of the subprime mortgage market set off
a revaluation of all asset classes and
led to a rather extended credit crunch
we bankers just don't get it every
decade or so we have to relearn that
covenants are important that risks do go
up and down but never disappear that the
greater fool theory now known as
securitization collateral debt
obligations and the light do not last
long and it's sooner but most often
later it will all come back to roost
Wells Fargo by the way did not
participate in this charade our
responsible lending values that are
included in our vision values of
booklets which saved us we did not offer
any no dock option or negative
amortization loans to subprime borrowers
these exotic subprime mortgage loans
were not only economically unsound they
were not appropriate for many borrowers
we lost 4 percent market share in our
mortgage business for three years
between 2005 and 7
160 billion dollars in origination zin
2006 alone in hindsight we were glad we
did for similar reasons we also did not
participate to any significant degree in
elated in the latest wall Wall Street
fats such as collateral debt obligations
structured investment vehicles to hold
assets off balance sheets hedge fund
financing off-balance sheet conduits low
covenant or no covenant large highly
leveraged loans we do not hold in our
money market mutual funds any
collateralized debt obligations any
commercial paper obligations directly
backed by subprime debt and so on and so
on another area we seem to do things
differently from others is management
succession in general and CEO succession
in particular years ago at Norwest we
put in a policy that all members of the
management committees the top 50 or so
people in our company had to retire not
later than an end of the year that they
became 65 now this was not done because
we think people over 65 cannot continue
to contribute to corporations it was
done for succession planning purposes it
takes many years to prepare someone to
take over senior positions at a company
the size and complexity of Wells Fargo
for senior positions it may take three
to five years for CEO position even
longer the sixty-five in your out policy
was put in place to ensure that everyone
including the board knew there was a
time certain that someone retire and so
plans can be made to select the best
candidates and give them the necessary
experience to handle the new job so we
ask all committee members to give us a
minimum of two years notice and and and
so this is 65 in your out policy is
really something more akin to a term
limit it ensures that there will be a
well-timed process to select the best
placement and the replacement candidate
would also know approximately when the
position would be available it could be
sooner but it would not be later than
that date and that's how we handled see
a CEO succession at Wells Fargo I don't
think the old CEO should stay beyond 65
to play the role of coach as
the new CEO was selected with 18 months
to two years before become CEO and the
old CEO becomes chairman and it helps
coach the succession process I think the
old CEO should give up his CEO in that
two-year period and remain a full-time
chairman until his age of 65 expires
now Wells Fargo followed this process
with with our CEO succession and in fact
the CEO succession started about seven
years before John Stumpf was selected in
July of 2007 by the way I would have
retired at the end of last year but
because we acquired Wachovia and because
of the financial crisis I was asked to
stay on for an extra year to help
integrate the acquisition and and help
with the crisis let me conclude by
asking you this question what is the
most important metric in business if you
had to pick only one metric to evaluate
how well a company is performing and how
likely would perform in the future what
would that be if I have learned anything
over the past 40 years it is this the
key to the bottom line is actually the
top line the only way to consistently
grow profits is to consistently grow
organic risk adjusted revenue if
customers are giving you more of their
business as evidenced by organic revenue
growth you know you must be doing a lot
of things right you must have
competitive products you must have good
service you must have good people who
understand customers needs
you must be priced about right your
technology must be competitive the
opposite is also true
if you're not generating organic revenue
you have major problems you have major
problems cutting costs only lasts for so
long and will probably even reduce
future revenue financial engineering is
more often a long-term negative than a
positive if you believe that revenue is
the key metric then a CEO you must be
lead by example
you must be customer focused call on
customers make sales calls with team
members and why
the top I have probably made an average
of two customer calls or customer visits
every day in my business career I don't
ever remember that being considered
important when I was at the Stanford
Business School acquisitions that grow
revenue after being acquired can never
be good investments for very long in my
opinion revenue growth is so important
that you shouldn't even make an
acquisition unless the revenue growth of
the combined Enterprise is higher than
the sum of the revenue growth of the two
companies if they had remained separate
entities so in my opinion it's all about
organic risk-adjusted revenue growth
year after year after year by the way we
have been Wells Fargo has been growing
revenue at double-digit rates for twenty
years twelve percent annual compound
rate for example so it's indeed been
quite a story and quite a journey it is
really a story of the opportunity
presented by capitalism and the free
enterprise system
it's amazing what opportunities are out
there speaking of capitalism I thought
you'd like to know my definition of
capitalism and how it differs from other
political and economic systems it is
particularly relevant given what's going
on in Washington today first socialism
that's when you have two cows and the
government gives one to your neighbor
communism
that's when you have two cows you had to
give both to the government and the
government distributes half the milk to
the people and the other half spoils on
the way to being delivered fascism
that's when you have two cows you have
to give all the milk to the government
officials the officials sell the milk
and deposit the proceeds in their Swiss
bank account and then there's capitalism
you have two cows you sell one of them
and you buy a bull that's capitalism
if I have learned anything in my 42
years of business it is this success
without fun never last fun without
success
isn't much fun my wish for all of you is
to have both fun and success in your
business career thank you for inviting
me back to my roots I wish all of you
the best in your career and you have as
much fun as I've had in mind I now be
happy to answer any questions you may
have thank you very much
you talk I read a quote from Alan
Greenspan nine months or so ago where he
said if he were 50 years younger he'd
start a bank and wondering if you agree
with that sentiment and if you do how
that might apply to someone in our shoes
that's going out in the working world
well I don't know about starting a bank
because it's you know it's a difficult
thing to do and it takes time and a lot
of capital to proceed but I think it's
the financial services business and
that's why I'll change the word from
bank manager is one of the great
industries in the world you know money
never declines it you know it's it grows
forever and we're you're basically in
the money business if you're in
financial services and so you have an
industry that's that's always going up
and there's not many of that you know
you can have too much food you can have
too much wine but I don't know of anyone
who has too much money so I think it's a
great business you mentioned your
business units are all very
decentralized how did you leverage the I
guess the integrated side of things so
how did you manage your business unit so
they were integrated well being also
decentralized it's really our secret
sauce you know we operate these
decentralized businesses but from a
customer standpoint we hope to be viewed
as one Wells Fargo so we we partner
between the businesses so that we can
deliver all the various products and
services that these decentralized
companies are manufacturing as one to
the customer it's a very difficult
process it's it's kind of all explained
in our vision and values but it really
you have to completely organize your
company from your technology to your
incentive systems to your structure to
your reward and recognition a system
that encourages this behavior and it's a
little it's literally hundreds of small
things that make that happen and the way
I explain this is that is the bad news
is this is hard to do the good news is
this is hard to do and it's a little bit
like Walmart does anyone not know what
what Walmart's strategy
and everyone knows it
low cost etc but it's it's how they do
that strategy that nobody can duplicate
and it like ours everyone sees the
benefit of cross selling now but it's
very hard to do so your competitive
advantage is it's a superior superior
business model a superior business model
that's easy doesn't stay superior for
long a bad business model that's hard is
of course the worst thing you can do but
a superior business model that's hard to
do actually is the upper right hand
corner you can have a competitive
advantage for a long time if it's a
superior business model and hard just
had a quick question on you know city
had already bid for the Kobe I suppose
there's a lot of coverage in the press
but was like the thought process was
well like you know bidding for VOC obeah
when city had already done so and when
the stock hit $7.80 or around that
figure did you ever think that it was a
bad move you know back in March well no
I guess the short answer you know it
gets back to what I was trying to say
before you know the the conventionalism
in my experience if if you only had two
choices to make follow the conventional
wisdom or do the opposite if you did the
opposite you would be better off and I'm
not saying you should do that I'm saying
the conventional wisdom is wrong in my
opinion so much of the time now but
again I don't you got to pay attention
to it because it you know there's
usually some truth to it but you you
just have to have that your own
conviction come to the your own
conclusion do that quantitative analysis
listen to your people forget ego do the
right thing and usually it will be
opposite or different from the
conventional wisdom and that's how you
do things you know again when do you buy
you buy when things are great or when
things are in trouble and when do people
buy
this is not hard if you have a cyclical
business if you just buy it here and
perform on average you're going to
perform a lot better than if you buy it
up here and and it's cyclical and most
all businesses are cyclical so it's
things like that and so our market share
and our acquisition strategy has always
been greater and by a huge degree in the
so-called bad times so you talked a lot
about acquisitions and culture how would
you characterize the difference between
while Covey's culture and in Wells
Fargo's and what have you done to really
sort of blend the two cultures together
to have a cohesive unit yeah the the
basic part what the problem that happen
with Wachovia is they started out as a
as a regional bank and made a lot of
acquisitions where the theory was and
the former CEO Crutchfield basically
said I've got to get bigger to be better
and that's earlier in my speech that's
very dangerous and he bought things at
very high prices and got into problems
so then they had to cut cost then decide
to go into brand-new businesses because
they were fairly narrowly focused saw
the benefits of diversity a little late
and thought they had to catch up
and so they when an investment banking
they went into the mortgage business at
the peak of the cycle and and so what
happened is they had some a lot of
problems that were caused by the failed
implementation of a strategy but the
fundamental businesses were actually
quite strong that they're being masked
by the mistakes they made by going into
Investment Banking and trading by going
in the pickup a and the savings business
they way overpaid for certain
acquisitions and had to make that up
through cost-cutting and so on and we
know what happened and Wells we've done
is sliced off all the bad things we
don't do the things that got him into
trouble we are paying part of the
purchase price of the difference we 90
billion and 12.7 is writing off all the
problems in there
to pay portfolio but the underlying
people are very culturally similar the
businesses are very similar and we will
this will turn out to be the best deal
ever done thank you thank you so much
for joining us a day my question is you
mentioned earlier that you have a very
keen focus on revenue growth and you
also mentioned that you guys are
expanding your other business lines such
as Investment Banking but actually those
two things in combination many people
said over the last five years are
precisely what led us into the crisis
today because retail banks were focusing
on growing the revenue diversifying all
their risk on Wall Street and that's
kind of how we ended up in the situation
we had last year so how do you feel as a
bank you guys can move forward with
those two things in mind and not face
whatever the next crisis may be well as
I said is that I think that the cultures
that existed back then we wouldn't have
gone into Investment Banking that has
changed now when I thought about
investing I'm really talking about the
meat and potatoes of Investment Banking
you know underwriting debt and equity
and so on we don't we did not do and
will not do the trading activities the
CDOs the structured products they didn't
make any sense anyway so but the we
could even be in the basic part of
Investment Banking because of the
cultures that exist but it's all gone
now and so today we think as I said we
were probably in the top ten now we'll
be in the top five now if that culture
changes back to the old way we will just
wind that business down if we can't
compete I don't see that happening this
is a fundamental change it's going to be
around if not forever for at least ten
years and if anything I think the
industry will move even closer to you
know a culture like Wells Fargo than it
even is today and and one reason that
will occur is I think you're going to
have
close watch by regulators in this
industry for a long time and even if
they wanted to they're not going to be
allowed to do it other than going into
an unregulated hedge fund or whatever
but it's not going to be done through an
investment banking environment my
opinion we'll see I worked at Perla
Weinberg which advised was an advisor in
the Wachovia
Co via Wells Fargo transaction and you
guys really have something unique and
you spoke about choosing people was your
key role I was just wondering if you
could offer some advice as far as when
you're choosing people what to what were
the key components are any advice
related to that well I'd say most of our
our senior people are homegrown we like
to get bring people in early in your
life experience the culture see the most
successful ones and promote them etc we
but we do the mostly outside people we
bring in or through acquisitions so
again we get we don't bring a lot of
people in that haven't been getting into
senior positions that haven't been with
us for at least 10 years so it's kind of
homegrown is how we do that and we get
we want people who have great values who
are smart but but do believe in this in
teamwork and and really caring about
customers and their communities and so
forth and we think that's more important
as I said then then brains at the 99
percent level
okay